spring has arrived here Ernie
and that's bad news for the barnacle
geese the breed in these mountains
many nests have failed but not this one
[Music]
three chicks they're lucky to have made
it forced by the early spring the
parents rushed to their migration they
arrived exhausted the female sat on me
for 25 days she's lost 30% of her body
weight
but for this family the greatest
challenge is still to come the parents
chose to nest on this 400 foot pinnacle
it's the only way to evade predators
just one problem the grass they ate is a
mile away by the river and barnacle
geese can't feed their young in the nest
if the chicks can't feed with only 36
hours EPFL staff and these chicks won't
be able to fly for another month
the parents are living proof there is a
solution just not an easy
dad leads the way but the chicks are
instinctively bonded to Mum
[Music]
where she goes
they follow
really
incredibly it survived
but it stunned
and now dangerously exposed
Oh
one chick gone now hope rests with the
other to the back of the spire is a
shorter drop but it's much harder to
avoid the rocks
for this chick
there will be no escape the third and
last surviving chick
[Music]
[Music]
the snow cushions the impact but offers
no grip
[Music]
[Music]
only around 50% of chicks hatched on
these cliffs make it through the first
month
with the seasons increasingly
unpredictable fewer chicks will survive
but this chick at least has defied the
odds
you
[Music]